a new day is upon us
a new generation built to fight
together we are unstoppable
are you ready
[Music]
killing spree
double kill hello let's do
some damage
return it to base
ordinance drop inbound
the flag is ours
please call at your earliest convenience
now show me what you can do
[Music]
i am so excited to have tom alex and
quinn
from 343 industries gentlemen thank you
for being here thanks for having us
now i've watched this multiplayer
trailer numerous times
and i want to see some specific moments
from it so we can break it down
so can we roll the trailer to 15 seconds
in and let's talk about a new character
a new day is upon us a new generation
built to fight together
we are unstoppable
are you ready
all right now who is this character she
looks like she's in charge
uh your your senses are right there
she's very much in charge that's
commander laurette she's in charge of
the spartan academy
which is the kind of contextual rapper
that the whole multiplayer universe
lives in
she is basically training the new
generation of spartans to you know
become better
and that's really where everything wraps
around um i really love this character
and then what's cool is
not only is it kind of the contextual
wrapper for the game but it's also we
have a whole suite of academy features
we call them
where there's a tutorial that teaches
the players the fundamental basics of
the game there's weapon drills that let
you practice with every weapon that
exists in the game
and get improve your skills with those
and then there's a whole thing we call
training mode which lets you play
against bots
on any map basically in the game and
lets you experiment with the toys and
kind of learn the flows of everything so
we really want to bring players on board
at the game and
again under her orders and her charge
now
i want to go to 50 seconds in the
trailer because there was a lot of
action
going on and i want to check that out
noscope
now you may have noticed i sat up in my
chair a little bit on that one because
there was a lot going on there so please
if you can break that down let me know
what we were seeing there's a lot to
break down i don't know if we got enough
time to get
all the way into it um but the some of
the the
things that i really love when i look at
that trailer is that that first sequence
with a player they have the bulldog
shotgun they're running through
shotgunning enemies they grab the
commando off the
off the rack put some shots in loch
sensor like
there's all sorts of different things
that the player is interacting with and
that's the sandbox that's what we call
the sandbox the toys that is at the
disposal for our players hands and
and we just really love that that moment
in the trailer where they have the
grapple shot
they look up grapple the ceiling and
then in midair
no scope snipe an enemy come all the way
down back whack a foe
and and then the rest is history as you
just see what happened in that trailer
but that's just
some of the stuff that that players can
do and that's actually the game that's
not
just a movie for cinematic experience
like that is the game that
if players are good enough put in time
they can actually do the things that you
see in that trailer
yeah and few things are more important
to halo multiplayer
than like interacting with the sandbox
and combining it picking it up off the
map and
combining it into awesome play styles so
what we did was
um every sandbox item in the game when
it spawns it's spawning on an object in
the map so you can see where those
things can be found
and then it also tells you the respawn
time of that item when it's going to
come back and you always know
i can go grab that commando over at this
spot like that
that guy did so and then when the
players you know accrue all those
awesome items and do awesome things
you know you heard the return of jeff
steitzer the multiplayer announcer
uh shouting out medals so we always want
to give players medals when they do
really cool things
so you heard some there and you'll hear
some later on in the trailer
that's awesome see when i watch that to
me that's halo that's halo to me i
absolutely love that now let's skip
ahead a little bit more
into the trailer to 57 seconds i heard a
voice
so i want to know what this voice is
let's let's see it
hello let's do some damage
so that is the player's uh personal ai
um so
in halo 5 there was a squad leader that
uh announced you know when weapons are
going to come up
and other things going on in the match
and in infinite we have the player
like chief has cortana uh they have a
personal ai in their helmet uh that is
kind of telling them these things
uh and it's also another way that
players can um
show their personality on their in their
characters so there's multiple
personalities and characters for the
player to choose um so that the the
right ais and their helmet uh helping
them out in combat
i want to skip ahead a little further
here because i think i might have saw a
big team battle so so let's go to a
minute 40 and check that out
return it to base
ordinance drop inbound
the flag is ours
please call at your earliest convenience
that looked like big team battle to me
what what what's coming new what are we
going
to
do in big team battle in the infinite i
mean it's not even just that i mean
part it actually opens with actually a
4v4 with a vehicle's map called behemoth
in
at the beginning so we actually are
bringing vehicles back into the 4v4
arena but then yes it definitely
transitions into the 4v or the 12v12
actually btb part of the game where
we're actually making it a bigger team
battle this time
really wanting to index into the battle
fantasy with the more players
where instead of like vehicles just
spawning around the map we have pelicans
drop them off we have ordinance pods
that drop in new weapons
and inside of that whole time you have
the battle commander lorette talking in
your ear
giving you orders and trying to kind of
encourage you to play around but really
just bringing the whole
sandbox in the play style around this
whole battle experience that we're
building
yeah tom brings up some good points
there of
of commander lorette and this you've got
your commander on the comms
and then you've got the pelicans
dropping vehicles and items off you've
got drop pods everything it's just
like this this theater of war that this
time around it it says this 12 b12
bigger team battle if you will and just
that last
that that ending segment which is like a
capture the flag match is just so
beautiful and awesome where you've got
the pelican drop the banshee off teams
fight over it
your you and your teammate are just
making a beeline for the banshee your
teammate gets picked off by the sniper
and like oh no and then you get the
skewer
take that sniper out jump into the
banshee and you hit the jets and fly up
into the sky and go for the enemy flag
that is
that to us is uh what is so exciting
about
this version of big team battle with all
the toys all the vehicles
the modes coming back the maps the brand
new maps that you see there i mean it's
it's going to be an amazing experience
yeah trust me
i cannot wait to get my hands on it for
myself but
let's move on i want to go to 208 in the
trailer
because i i think it's all samurai so
let's check that out let's go to 208 in
the trailer
now show me what you can do
[Music]
okay so i guess next would be a ninja
because that was definitely a samurai so
kind of talk about that so we're going
to start seeing some more customization
with the armor coming in yeah
i mean that is a samurai spartan armor
and so it'll be
an armor you'll be able to unlock for
free in the first season which is super
cool players will be able to
equip it you know gain more armor pieces
and customization options for etcetera
across the season
and then we actually have more of this
stuff kind of coming down the line with
there's actually some really cool ideas
that we're seeing in uh that our team
that's building that stuff so there'll
be a lot of other cool armors besides
just the really core
halo spartan armors there'll be some
other different kind of twists and
things for players to play with
awesome look now before we get out of
here first of all i want to thank
all of you for being here to talk about
halo infinite i'm excited
i can't wait to get my hands on it and
play it but before we do leave
is there anything else that you want to
bring up and let fans out there know
about
well i'm excited for people to actually
get their hands on it like yourself so i
mean if people sign up on our halos
insiders program we have in the summer
we have a uh a technical preview that
we're going to be launching and so
people to finally get they put their
hands on the sticks and i'm just really
excited for players to actually finally
get to play the game we're working on
yeah and then on launch day halo
infinite multiplayer is free to play
which is new to the franchise
the team is super excited uh to
hopefully bring in you know all sorts of
fans that have potentially never
experienced the franchise or haven't
played in a long time to just
try it out come in and try it out with
your friends me with my buddies if i
have some friends out there that haven't
played halo before i'm like well it's
free just come on let's
jump in download it let's check it out
and if it's for you it's for you if it's
not then hey it's not but
i don't think it'll be for you so i'm
excited for it yeah that's the
the other big key of that point is a
pc right like this is this is a pc game
as well we've been putting a lot of
effort into that
so not only is it going to be console
but also pc it free to play
like the barrier to entry is so low and
that has us excited and
i think as we really just to really
think about it as we've been working on
this game
and as developers when you work on a
game you want to get that game out there
and that almost seems like for us that's
the finish line but in reality
it's going to be the starting line for
for all of us for
us and the halo fans day one
there's going to be a bunch of content
there and things that are exciting and
good
but then we're going to add more content
we're going to add more maps we're going
to add more
modes and weapons and vehicles equipment
items
and it's just the beginning of this
whole journey that that we've been on
for a while and we're going to take
everyone else with us as we as the game
comes out i'm excited
gentlemen again thank you so much now
for fans who want to learn even more
about halo infinite multiplayer
check out the brand new deep dive video
with the whole multiplayer team
over on halowaypoint.com and allow me to
give a big thanks to everyone who's
joined us today
whether you play your favorite games on
xbox pc or game pass
the next 12 months will be nothing short
of spectacular
it has been my absolute honor to be your
host
and share this experience with you but
before i go
here's a gameplay deep dive from the
team behind the highly anticipated
scarlet nexus